-Making her US TV debut
performing "Narcissist,"
please welcome
Lauren Spencer-Smith.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ They're always charismatic,
and they'll turn up the charm ♪
♪ Their words do something magic
saying no is really hard ♪
♪ They're over-generous,
you'll never pay the bills ♪
♪ They'll fall in love
in seconds ♪
Die for you or probably kill ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And after six months,
you'll feel really stupid ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I promise that it's not
your fault you fell for it ♪
♪ 'Cause one little fight
breaks into war ♪
♪ Feels like you're dying
on a bathroom floor ♪
♪ You'll make an excuse,
they'll say that it's you ♪
♪ And the mirror's
telling you it's true ♪
♪ Won't leave, can't stay,
how much are you gonna take? ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll always
get the blame ♪
♪ It feels like this,
but that's just how it is ♪
♪ When you love a narcissist ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ So if you're feeling crazy,
I wouldn't be surprised ♪
♪ The only thing they're good
at is knowing how to gaslight ♪
♪ Then make you feel like
you're the most ♪
♪ Beautiful in the world ♪
♪ While they're sleeping
with another girl ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And after six months,
you'll feel really stupid ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I promise that it's not
your fault you fell for it ♪
♪ 'Cause one little fight
breaks into war ♪
♪ Feels like you're dying
on a bathroom floor ♪
♪ You'll make an excuse,
they'll say that it's you ♪
♪ And the mirror's
telling you it's true ♪
♪ Won't leave, can't stay,
how much are you gonna take? ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll always
get the blame ♪
♪ It feels like this,
but that's just how it is ♪
♪♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh ♪
♪ 'Cause I felt like this,
so I know how it is ♪
♪ When you love a narcissist ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!